.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE WELCOME.
WE SAT DOWN WITH ONE OF THE
GREATEST FIGURES IN AMERICAN
SPORTS, KEITH HERNANDEZ FORMERLY
CARDINALS AND METS.
FIRST BASEMAN AND TWO WORLD
SERIES TITLES.
HE SMOKED CIGARETTES IN THE
DUGOUT AND PLAYED HUNGOVER.
HOW DID YOU PLAY AT THAT HIGH OF
A LEVEL.
>> HOW DO PEOPLE PLAY AT A HIGH
LEVEL WITH A HANGOVER?
>> CAN'T MAKE A HABIT OF IT.
IT WILL CATCH UP TO YOU.
CHICAGO WAS THE PLACE.
WRIGLEY FIELD, IT IS A SAME
BALLPARK THAT WHEN RUTH MADE THE
POINT, HOME RUN.
YOU ARE IN THE CLUBHOUSE, TINY
CLUBHOUSE.
TINY.
YOU HAD TO WALK UP THE STAIRS,
THEY THROW BEERS AT YA.
I LOVED WRIGLEY.
YOU SAT IN YOUR LOCKER, BABE
RUTH, LOU GEHRIG'S HERE I AM IN
THE SAME LOCKER AS THEM.
GETTING BACK TO YOUR POINT,
RUSSIAN DIVISION.
YOU CAN GO INTO A BAR RUSSIAN
DIVISION EMPTY.
1:00 PACKED.
4:00.
STAYED OUT UNTIL 4:00, DON'T GO
TO BED.
JUST STAY UP.
I DID IT THREE TIMES IN MY
CAREER.
I HAD TO DO IT.
AND I GOT OUT TO FIRST BASE AND
SAID LORD, PLEASE, NO GROUND
BALLS.
NO TOUGH PLAYS.
PROMISE I'LL NEVER DO IT AGAIN.
>> Tucker: HOW DID YOU PLAY?
>> I DON'T REMEMBER.
TY DID GOOD WHEN I WAS TIRED OR
HAD -- I FOCUSSED MORE IF SAY I
HAD A HEADACHE OR FOR WHATEVER
REASON.
I FOCUSSED MORE.
CAN'T LET YOUR TEAM DOWN.
IT IS A TEAM GAME.
I CAN'T IN MY RIGHT MIND I AM
TIRED OR HAD TOO MANY, HUNGOVER
HOLDING A RUNNER ON AND COME OFF
THE BAG WITH A PITCH.
IF I SLOUGH IT AND DON'T DO AN
EXTRA STEP FIRST AND THIRD, LET
THE TEAM DOWN COULDN'T DO IT.
I BORE DOWN MORE WHEN I WAS
SICK, OR IF I ADD HAD A FEW TOO
MANY BEERS.
>> Tucker: NEVER MISSED A GAME
FROM BEING HUNGOVER?
>> GOD NO.
HECK NO.
NO WAY.
>> Tucker: THAT IS PRETTY
IMPRESSIVE.
>> NO IT IS NOT.
CAN'T LET MY TEAMMATES DOWN.
I SLEPT UNTIL NOON.
SAY I NORMAL HOTEL BAR 1:00,
1:30.
I WOULDN'T WAKE UP UNTIL 12:00
NOON.
I WOULD CALL ROOM SERVICE,
COFFEE, DANISH, TURN ON ABC AND
WATCH "ALL MY CHILDREN."
[LAUGHTER]
>> YOU WATCHED IT ON THE ROAD?
>> RELIGIOUSLY.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE WATCHING SOAP
OPERA
OPERAS?
>> JUST TH